it might be time to grab your tinfoil
hats because the aliens are coming and
apparently a lot of them they've been
almost 1 000 documented UFO sightings in
the UK since January 2021 and they even
seem to be targeting certain areas of
the UK more than others with most
sightings taking place in Greater
Manchester London and Chester now at the
end of July three former military
officials in the U.S told Congress they
believe aliens are real and the
government are purposely concealing
evidence a Former Intelligence official
went on record to say the US government
is in possession of non-human biological
remains
if you believe we have crashed craft
stated earlier do we have the bodies of
the pilots who piloted this craft
biologics came with some of these
recoveries yeah were they I guess human
or non-human biologics non-human and
that was the assessment of people with
direct knowledge on the program I talked
to that are currently still on the
program
so should we all be gearing up for an
alien invasion or is it all a bit of a
conspiracy joining me now to discuss all
this UFO ologist and host of weaponized
podcast Jeremy Corbell and UFO expert
the one who investigated UFOs for the US
Ministry of Defense Nick Pope gentlemen
thank you Nick I'll start with you uh
you were the person who obtained and
released the military filmed Pentagon
confirmed UFO videos that put into
motion the First Congressional hearings
on UFOs no for 50 years and the recent
hearings as well you were part of that
so I mean it when we approached this
topic people can get a bit silly about
it you know we had the X-Files music
talk about alien invasions but this is
very much your career your life's work
do you think people take it seriously
enough
well they do in the United States sure
we've just had these Congressional
hearings and uh you know this this
person David grush who's testified was
verifiably part of the unidentified
aerial phenomena Task Force if he was
making this up he would be committing a
federal offense by the way because this
was under oath he has apparently given
the Senate intelligence committee the
house intelligence committee and the
Inspector General of the intelligence
Community a very specific checkable
facts project names locations a list of
people who are prepared to testify this
is being taken very very seriously now
as a defense and national security issue
in the United States and it's it's a
long time that the British government
reopened their UFO program by the way
that was terminated at the end of 2009.
indeed and uh Jeremy rather sorry I
should I think I misnamed you at the
start there in terms of the recent
Congressional hearings that we heard in
the US struck me most was that it was
announced but to very little Fanfare
people didn't seem to care it's almost
like they've been through a pandemic and
there's a war going on and the price of
everything is through the roof and uh
Alien suddenly aren't that interesting
or worrisome to them anymore
well first of all that's incorrect and
hello Nick nice to see you this is a
completely different situation than is
being shown right here you said put on
your tin foil hats people should put on
their battle helmets right now this is
being taken seriously from the world
public it's a serious topic and people
need to understand why it's a serious
Topic at this time right now you've been
told something historic you've been told
something historic from your government
you've been told something historic from
my government right now what you've been
told is that UFOs are indeed real that
there is a technological aspect to it
and the world needs to catch up with
consensus reality it is being taken very
seriously at the highest levels of
government and for reasons that are
really good one is strategic surprise
it's really simple to understand that if
somebody has technology that we don't
have that can outpace outmaneuver and
outperform our greatest fighter planes
and Weapons Systems like Commander David
fraver who testified at that hearing
told you then this is something that it
should be understood differently than
how it's being presented right now well
you've got an opportunity to respond to
that
yeah I do no I
this is this is all absolutely serious I
I mean a few a few months ago this sort
of thing would have been maybe just
dismissed but now it's been discussed in
the United States Congress in the
scientific and academic Community there
is I think a growing realization that
this is real and there are going to be
more things coming in the next few weeks
and months by the way NASA is doing a
study as we speak they're going to
report uh later this month there will be
more hearings in the United States
Congress and there will be more
whistleblowers coming forward speaking
out on the record under oath on the
floor of Congress this is a fact
Jeremy is is there an extent to the
amount of information that normal people
can handle is there an argument the
government should withhold some
information
the poison right now is the lack of
information and the lack of proper
reporting on this the only remedy and
the only cure is to inform the American
and Global public we are living in a
data-rich environment when it comes to
foes or UAP as you say but that the real
danger is secrecy and lack of
transparency and what Nick said is
correct and I know because I've directly
spoken with the witnesses that have
already taken action that is not yet
public to come forward and America will
lead by example as we do at our greatest
moments in history but this is not an
American issue this is a global issue
it's not just bipartisan and that's why
you see AOC and representative Tim
birchett leading the charge here from
people who are under oath who have been
designated to protect our national
interests as well as our Global
interests and we need to really look at
how we treat David grush right now
because these hearings this historic
hearings that you saw was the first time
in history that people are talking with
first-hand information where they
directly engaged UFOs in a combat
situation as well as in training times
so what we see right now is an embolding
and an empowering of people who desire
to come forward because it is the right
the just the ethical and the legal thing
to do but we need to see how David grush
who is the only whistleblower that was
standing up there the other two people
they were just testifying George Knapp
and I my mentor on journalism we also
put something on Congressional Record so
that the public would be informed I
should look at that both of you thank
you very much for your time we've
learned quite a bit there about UFOs